[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINA LEE: Hi, I'm Tina Lee,
founder of MotherCoders,
a nonprofit that helps
moms gain the tech skills
they need to compete
in the new economy,
and provide on-site child
care while they learn.
I'm a strong ambitious woman.
Is there anyone
else here like that?
[CHEERING]
Yeah.
Good, because I need
your help getting
to the Planet of Belonging.
Why?
Because there we'll
get a fair shot
at achieving our potential.
We'll find inclusion,
fairness, and fulfillment.
It's very different than the
planet that we're on now.
Right now, on the
planet that we're on,
it's not working for everyone.
On Planet of Meh there's
systemic inequality based
on things like race and gender.
There's also this notion
that your value is measured
by time rather than impact.
And lastly, worse
yet, we're organized
around the idea of
a nuclear family,
even though families have never
worked that way, especially
today, when 46% of households
there are two parents working
full-time jobs.
So you're wondering,
who is it working for?
This guy, right?
It's designed for him.
Young, white, male,
straight, preferably
with no student loan debt or
caregiving responsibilities.
Who does that leave out?
Everyone else.
But since we're here celebrating
International Women's Day,
I'd like to focus specifically
on what is happening to women.
For starters, we get paid less.
In the US, women are paid
$0.66 to every man's dollar,
for similar work.
And if you're a woman
of color, disabled,
queer, or a little
older, you're probably
going to fare even worse.
And if you think you're immune
to this because you're in tech,
I'm sorry to tell you, are not.
In fact, there's still
a pay gap in tech,
and there's only a small
percentage of venture funding
that's going to startups
with women founders.
It's no wonder we
have a leadership gap.
And one of the main reasons why
women, our careers get stalled
is because we're society's
primary caregivers.
70% of us spend 20 hours
or more per week caring
for kids, parents, even
family and friends.
And because no good
deed goes unpunished,
we end up getting
paid less for it,
because we will trade
money and career
advancement for flexibility.
And if you become a
mom, which 81% of you
will do or already
have done, you'll
get hit with a mommy tax.
That's because you'll be
deemed less competent and less
committed to your
career once you
become a mom, while the
opposite happens to dads.
They get a fatherhood
bonus, because now they're
more deserving and
more competent.
So here's me, right?
Yellow, I am a daughter
of poor immigrants,
and I have two girls.
We're so screwed!
We're getting out
of here, and we're
taking my husband Steve
with us, because he's
a really good dude.
We're all packing up.
We're going to
Planet of Belonging,
because there it
won't matter where
we came, from how much
money we have, who we love.
We'll just work together to
meet everyone's basic needs
and still have enough time
to do the awesome stuff we
were meant to do.
Notice affordable childcare.
I am so excited about this
idea that I've already
started building a crew.
A team of women,
amazing women that
come through the
MotherCoders program.
And with your help, we're
going to build this army
into a national force.
But here are some more
ways you can help.
If your company doesn't already
have these retention policies,
please help them implement some.
And you can even double down
by tying executive compensation
directly to diversity goals,
or just giving all the women
a raise to close the gap.
Then let's cultivate
a culture of care.
It turns out, when people
feel connection and warmth
at their workplace, they
report higher levels
of satisfaction and teamwork,
which translate directly
into higher
performance, more money.
And then safety.
Here is Google's formula for
building effective teams.
Notice that the first,
foremost ingredient
is psychological safety.
Yet our caregivers are
scared to tell their bosses
about their responsibilities.
And finally, to get to
the Planet of Belonging,
we're going to need
a lot of power.
Millennial power.
Thankfully, this
rising generation
will be the biggest
since the boomers,
and they'll also be the most
diverse and the most educated.
Especially the women.
And women right now control
85% of all consumer purchasing
decisions.
We actually have the economic
power to pull this off.
And don't forget we
have allies in men
like my husband Steve, who want
off the Planet of Meh, too.
So for the sake of each other
and everyone coming behind us,
I urge you to join us at
MotherCoders in our effort
to get to the
Planet of Belonging,
a new world where we will
all be given a chance
to be our best selves.
Thank you, and please come
see us at the community fair.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]